good evening i'm happy to welcome you
all to the last of this year's frankie
lectures in the humanities here at the
whitney humanities center
each year the annual frankie lectures in
the humanities are organized in
conjunction with an upper level
undergraduate humanities seminar
the lectures are made possible by the
generosity of richard and barbara frank
frankie and are intended to present
important topics in the humanities to a
wide and general audience
the fall 2021 frankie lectures in the
humanities have been organized in
conjunction with the yale college
seminar mass incarceration in the soviet
union and the united states taught by
professors timothy snyder and jason
stanley
tonight we are pleased and honored to
welcome laurie groom
professor gruen is the william griffin
professor of philosophy at wesleyan
university
she is the author or editor of 15 books
and dozens of important chapters and
articles
she works at the intersection of
practical ethics and political
philosophy
groon is a founding faculty member and
the creator of the faculty advisory
committee of the century center for
prisoner education at wesleyan
university
she has taught incarcerated students at
bayview correctional facility a women's
prison in chelsea new york now closed
the federal correction institution in
danbury connecticut when it was a
women's prison and cheshire correctional
institution in cheshire connecticut a
maximum security men's prison and york
correctional institution a women's
prison
and today she will present her her paper
on carceral logic
professor groon take it away
thank you so much professor stanley i'm
honored um to be here
um one of the things that i'm going to
do tonight is uh to talk through
two really conceptual um ideas carceral
logics on the one hand and an
abolitionist critique on the other um
and i realize that for many of you it's
the end of the semester
uh i understand um that it's there's a
lot going on so i really appreciate your
being here
um i also made some slides um that i'm
going to share now
and so at least
you'll be able to
follow along since we don't have
handouts
and the like
um so as professor stanley said
my talk is entitled
carceral logics
an abolitionist critique
you may remember the afternoon last
april 20th like many people across the
u.s you may have been tensely waiting to
learn what the minneapolis jury would
decide in the murder trial of former
police officer derek chauvin
who killed george floyd
due to the pandemic we all were able to
watch the trial and that would only have
been witnessed by family and locals if
we weren't in a pandemic
but as the judge read out the verdicts
on the three charges against chauvin
second degree murder
guilty
third degree murder
guilty
and second degree manslaughter guilty
there was a collective national sigh of
relief
and the reaction was emotional
television news cut away from regularly
scheduled programming to broadcast some
of the reactions the congressional black
caucus members for example were shown
huddled together looking at their phones
and other devices
nodding hugging as they listened to the
verdicts
citizens outside the courthouse also
watched on their phones they cheered
fists were raised high many people
looked up in the heavens
and gratitude
people held each other
and some broke down
and wept
there was a similar although more muted
emotional relief when the three men that
gunned down ahmad arbory were convicted
a few weeks ago
and a great deal of anger was generated
when kyle rittenhouse was found not
guilty of shooting three white men and
killing two of them joseph rosenbaum and
anthony hoover
it's undeniable
that many people felt deeply gratified
by the castle responses to chauvin's
callous cruelty
and the conviction of the men who killed
aubry
so many police officers and vigilantes
are not arrested or tried or convicted
of horrible crimes against black people
and sometimes white people
and so i want you to keep that feeling
of wanting to punish
close
while i talk about the logics that
underlie it
and why i think we need to break free of
these punitive impulses and abolish
carceral logics
in this talk i'll briefly unpack and
explore various ways that carceral
logics
shape excuse me
various ways that carcerologists shape
all
uh shape our social and political
relations
these harmful cultural logics i'll argue
hold us all captive in systems of
disposability
permanent exclusions
and they should be abolished
but let's start first by
talking about how i understand carceral
logics it has a lot of different
meanings and i want to be sure that we
all are on the same page with what
i think carceral logics are
so one way of thinking about it is that
it highlights and organizes the variety
of ways that our bodies and our minds
and our actions have been shaped by the
idea and practices of captivity
even for people who haven't been to
prison
and i want to just take a moment
here especially to say something about
those of us who think about and talk
about prisons who haven't been in prison
that is those of us who haven't been
locked up i mean i've been in a lot of
prisons as professor stanley just said
but that isn't important
those who are incarcerated or far
formerly incarcerated are really the
best people to talk about the weight of
carceral power and how they've
experienced it in their bodies and minds
and we have a lot to learn from them
i'll draw on their voices and what
they've taught me throughout my talk
but part of the reason that i'm
interested in talking about not carceral
power per se
but carceral logics
is that it's an ideology of capture and
containment that impacts all of us
those who are incarcerated those who are
formerly incarcerated and those of us
not yet incarcerated
i want to explore what sort of thinking
these cultural logics make possible and
perhaps more importantly what sorts of
ideas and practices they authorize and
what sorts of ideas and practices they
foreclose
i'll identify two types of carceral
logics
the first
is a carceral logic that as understood
is sort of organizing capture
surveillance and disposal
and i'll talk a little bit about that
and then i'm going to turn to a second
type of carceral logic which i think of
as an ideology of domination and i'll
say a little bit about domination
then after i talk about these carceral
logics and you get a sense of what i
mean
um i will then turn to talking about
why and how why we should abolish them
and how that might look
um okay and i'm i'm thinking that
um
most everyone in the audience today
having um has some sense of
the sort of shape of the actual car
system the the sort of bricks and mortar
and
razor wire so i'm not going to talk too
much about that
as i said it's a little bit more
conceptual what i'm going to be talking
about
but when we imprison humans
we i'm going to just say a little bit
now about it when we imprison humans we
harm them in ways that are both obvious
they're in conditions that can cause
physical suffering
and frustration
and ways that are not so obvious
long-term psychological impacts of
boredom
anxiety and a lack of control
here's how a group of incarcerated men
who were sentenced collectively to a
total of 225 years in a maximum security
prison describe a slice of their
experiences
and this is from a chapter
that they wrote in my edited volume
called uh the volumes called the ethics
of captivity um
and this piece that this comes from is
as you see here life behind bars
so what they say um and you could read
along
after our initial humiliation upon being
strip searched
when we enter prison
we we lose all control of our lives we
will eat bathe and shave when told
we'll be expected to follow direct
orders no matter how absurd or unfair
non-conflict compliance will be met with
force
the depressive environment tends to
stifle intellectual curiosity
we simply become too tired and sullen to
engage in intellectual pursuits
simply put we dwell in ourselves we're
not actively using our minds and in our
very real sense we're thus losing our
minds
the loneliness caused by prisons in
general and prison cells in particular
is exacerbated by the loss of intimacy
and the loving touch of friends and
family
those held captive are deprived so much
including the ability to make basic
choices
of course none of us is free
to make any kind of choices we might
want we're restricted in all sorts of
ways by the genders that were assigned
by our physical and cognitive abilities
by class by religion by race by
ethnicity
even by our species
we're restricted by state power and
other governmental and economic
institutions that prescribe all sorts of
choices and force others upon us
carceral prison spaces are particularly
stark
in their ways of limiting our and
reducing the choices that are available
for those who are within them
cages and cells and iron doors little
natural light concrete and steel razor
while and wire razor wire and metallic
noise
and these carceral spaces
um are designed in part
and organized by a carceral logic
that
makes these choices
impossible
there are cars but there are costable
spaces that function beyond prisons and
gulags
and those also control and contain
others immigration detention centers
zoos
laboratories psychiatric institutions
even some senior living places are sites
of containment surveillance and control
there are also often sites of undoing
the carceral spaces are not simply
punitive
and they do not merely serve as foucault
noted as socializing and disciplining
institutions and to sites of
surveillance
increasingly
we're seeing that they also function to
reinforce a permanent state of injury
and part of that injury is the
disposability of those who occupy those
spaces
some humans have always fallen into the
category of disposable or fungible
people stolen from africa in the
transatlantic slave trade are prime
examples but there are an estimated 27
million people in slavery today
kevin bales in his book disposable
people conservatively estimates that a
large number of
a larger sorry a larger number of people
than the whole population of canada
are currently enslaved
the bulk of these people approximately
15 to 20 million are in conditions of
bounded labor in india pakistan
bangladesh and nepal
they become enslaved as security against
a loan or when they inherited debt
in other words these persons have a
price
i won't go into kant at this moment but
if those of you who are aware of kant
will now recognize that these
disposable beings with a price are mere
things
and then they when they don't work to
their capacity they're disposed of
when you're disposable you have lesser
status
sometimes the status is a stat the
status of a thing
and this isn't only a slight or an
affront but a way of reminding both the
one being denied the status and others
around that one is in the category
deemed disposable abject
other
that's one way that the carceral logics
that i'm worried about operate
the other kind of logic as i mentioned
is one of domination
there are at least two ways that we can
think of domination
one that supports and maintains not just
disciplinary control of bodies but
taxonomies of power
the other upholds ontological exclusions
or outsideness and the violence it
authorizes
the first sort of domination is
characterized by its justificatory power
upholding oppressive institutions
relationships and practices
domination according to political
philosopher philip pettit occurs when a
person is in a position in which someone
has the power
to arbitrarily interfere
with choices they would otherwise have
been able to make
and this notion of domination is pretty
expansive
because the interference just needs to
be possible
in the form of a threat
it has wide reaching ramifications and
that one can internalize the potential
to be the victim of domination
and one can imagine one has the power to
dominate and so act as if it's their
privilege
and this way of thinking
naturalizes or normalizes domination
remedying this sort of carceral logic
is important in many contexts when the
dominator and the dominated exist on the
same plane
when they are at the same table as it
were what i'm thinking of here is that
the relationship of dominated and
dominator
or domination the dominator and the
submissive um
may this may be a relationship in which
both are recognized as having a capacity
to switch roles and the roles are just
at this particular juncture because of
particular political and social and
probably historical features of the
situation end up having that
um divergent um relationship of
domination and some submission but it's
not a it's it's a kind of fixable
domination as it were
um if you think about the example also i
was thinking teachers and students um
there's a certain relation of power
there
um but domination um
by over like overt domination that's
objectionable domination not just the
relationship of power but the
object
objectively problematic
um domination can be called out by the
student
similarly
students have certain amount of power
they can also be called out by a teacher
about their abuse of that power so i'm
get what i'm getting at here is that
this particular version of domination
sort of recognizes the possibility of
remedy
but there's a deeper
type of injury associated with carceral
logics of domination
for those for whom domination is a
condition of existence
this is what i meant earlier when i said
it has an ontological flavor
the idea here is that there's a category
the slave the prisoner the animal
and that category is fundamentally
lower status there's no way of objecting
to this domination relationship
um it's the condition of existence
this this carceral logic that these
categorical
individuals are subjected to goes beyond
this first sort of domination
here is a logic that serves as a
conceptual mechanism that fixes and
solidifies exclusions
it permanently marks another as an other
this sort of carceral logic is
especially obvious in anti-black racism
for example
okay so this was my brief discussion
of two types of carceral logics that i'm
concerned about
um i we can talk more um i hope we will
later um but these course carceral
logics organize our systems of captivity
for humans and i should add also for
animals
and they structure domination that
consistently denies many humans the very
chance of being free
carceral logics have also colonized our
minds
making it hard to imagine how we can
make any changes
this is how why we have the emotions we
have when chauvin was found guilty and
why
we more often have the disappointments
that we have when many of those in power
are not charged or tried or convicted
when they act with egregious violence
against the powerless
i have those too even though i've been
thinking about these issues for a really
long time i still have that it's not
possible to completely escape um the way
in which carceral logics have colonized
our thinking
it is really hard to get out of it in
other words um but i think we can
abolish these carceral logics from our
thinking and our feeling and our acting
and we can work at least to free our
imaginations and create the ground to
stand and think against such logics
and one way we can do that
is by thinking about abolition and
abolition
has a lot of different again like
carceral logics evolution is a big
category uh there's a lot of different
ways of understanding what it means many
people think of it in terms of the
abolition of
prisons
themselves
i'm thinking of it more in this context
as a way of
getting outside of carceral logic so
abolishing carceral logics um and i'll
talk a little bit about the history of
abolition as a notion as well
but i want us to sort of put aside the
notion of abolishing prisons even though
um that is not
it's consistent with what i'm saying but
it's not the focus of what i'm talking
about when i'm talking about abolition
so abolition as i understand it in this
uh discussion is a framework for
reimagining our own agency
for re-envisioning our communities
and for reframing our social and
political relations
in a fairly recent i think last year or
the year before new york times article
about geographer and abolitionist ruthie
gilmore
law professor james forman jr said that
quote what i love about abolition and
now used in my own thinking and when i
identify myself as an abolitionist this
is what i have in mind is the idea that
you imagine a world without prisons
and then you work to build that world
or in
my terms you imagine a world without
carceral logics and then you work to
build that world so abolition is
aspirational
imagining otherwise moving against
cultural logics will be trying we're
asked to think in fundamentally
different ways
thinking that's contextual relational
historical maybe even poetic
with a little bit of what devonia havis
a philosopher describes as alchemy we'll
need ingenuity to negotiate what seems
impossible
so before getting into how we might move
in the direction of imagining um
how to negotiate
impossibility or what seems impossible
let me say a little bit about the
history of abolition
so the term abolition is best known of
course in the context of opposition to
the atlantic slave trade
early abolitionists were opposed to the
violent accumulation of wealth due to
forced labor
according to
manisha sinha
in her book the slaves cause
abolitionists though primarily concerned
with resisting slavery
had
wide-reaching concerns and i'll leave
this up so you can see what she thinks
are as also being really important
and a part of what it was that
abolitionists the early avenue
abolitionists were doing
so
with the abolition of slavery after the
civil war
many abolitionists were actively
reimagining how to bring the ideals of
democracy into fuller practice so
democracy
was a big commitment of
these early abolitionists and the
abolitionists after
including importantly sociologist w.e.d
du bois in black reconstruction noted
that abolition democracy demanded the
structural reform of labor education and
opportunities now notice so we're going
from the thought of abolitioning
abolition of
the of slavery and forced labor um
practices to
a different way of thinking about how to
organize our
communities and the opportunities um and
resources that are available within
those communities so this is an
important point it wasn't enough to
emancipate black people from slavery
many envisioned building a free and
equal society in which the disadvantages
that emerged from the system of slavery
were not permanent
but as i was suggesting the second
version of carceral logics has a kind of
afterlife
um and that afterlife is something that
we see
at the end of reconstruction as well
and the re-implementation of the black
codes which perpetuated forms of
unfreedom for black people
for example
they could be prosecuted for not
carrying proof of employment which led
to incarceration and with the forced
labor
so in the south what this amounted to
was a conflict leasing program
and the growing population of black
prisoners um ended up going
back to work
back to work without pay
um and so and it was a extraordinarily
abusive system du bois quotes from a
southern white woman
um and this is what um
what she says
uh
in some states where convict labor is
sold to the highest bidder the cruel
treatment of the helpless human channel
in the hands of guards is such as no
tongue can tell nor pen picture
prison inspectors find convicts herded
together irrespective of age and there
were a lot of children actually a lot of
children
confined at night in shackles housed
sometimes
as has been found in old box cars
packed almost as closely as sardines in
a box
during the day oller worked under armed
guards who stand ready to shoot down any
who may attempt to escape from this hell
upon earth the modern american bastille
should one escape the bloodhounds
trained for the purpose are put upon his
tracks and the chances are that he will
be brought back severely flogged and put
in double shackles or worse
as these shocking conditions of convict
leasing became widely known
pressure built to end the practice and
one by one southern states
didn't renew
the or initiate the leases
alabama was the final state to end
convict leasing in 1928.
okay fast forward i'm a philosopher not
a historian sorry fast forward to 1970s
so 1928 to the 1970s lots happened but
we'll just fast forward
um there were a new form of abolition um
emerged and that was led a lot by
quakers
um and it was a form of abolition of
against
prisons and
importantly it's 1976
so you know that mass incarceration
really
wasn't really
full on in in that period but there were
nonetheless abolition prison
abolitionists
um
the first chapter of a book by that was
um put together by feihany knop
called instead of prisons um
with a group of quakers um and other
political
actors in the first chapter
um
they have comments from lawyers and
judges and prisoners and those employed
or formerly employed by prisons
authors activists and
many who condemned prisons
um
and these are just some of the examples
and i think it's really quite striking
um how a judge
a professor um at colombia a former uh
psychiat
psychiatrist
at sing-sing all were in favor
of abolishing uh the prisons and again
this is abolishing prisons um prior to
our uh current era of mass incarceration
okay that's my brief historical tour
um
now you may have some
concerns and reactions um about the idea
of abolition most people do
it invokes a variety
of
different kinds of feelings like
incredulity and disdain to curiosity and
excitement and these reactions also vary
depending on the context in which the
topic of abolition is being raised
and the ways that it's being discussed
so i want to give you this recent
example from 2017 the aclu conducted a
survey
that found that 61 of americans believe
that people who suffer from drug
addiction
and commit serious crimes don't belong
in prison but should receive
treatment and 87 percent
believe that when people with mental
health disabilities commit serious
crimes um that involve violence
they should be sent to mental health
programs where they can receive
treatment from professionals
so not to prison
so this is this is recent and this is a
huge majority of um
the
the u.s population such strong public
support for these non-carceral responses
to violent crimes
are i think really important to note
in a country that locks up over 2
million people
and his feminist scholar and
abolitionist joy james has noted
abolitionist alternatives to prisons are
already available for those with wealth
and power
she writes
existential whiteness money or capital
and connections to governing elites
allow offenders if prosecuted and
convicted
to be largely
directed to therapy counseling drug
treatment and expensive residential
treatment centers
but abolishing prisons
is only one way as i've suggested of
thinking about abolition
i think it's an important project uh
don't get me wrong i i'm involved in
that project um however tonight i'm
really thinking of
abolishing carceral logics um
and that is consistent as i said with
abolishing prim um prisons
um but i think i'm more interested
tonight in talking
about how we can end our acceptance
of punitive responses to crime
and other acts that are outside of the
accepted norms
and to begin imagining alternatives
to these carceral logics
in a society like ours that's organized
by profound inequality
abolitionists are working to develop
more just and meaningful social policy
that will help support community needs
and build alternative humane
institutions
these efforts involve promoting
non-reformist reforms
that are i think a really important idea
um that
allow for the development of policies
and practices that minimize harm
and also
at the same time don't contribute to or
reinforce carceral logics
so let me just give you some examples of
um
of non what i think our non-reformist
reforms we can discuss this further if
this is something um that you either
disagree with or or don't um
don't think makes sense but the program
the center for prison education which is
at wesleyan um is a program that i've
been involved in from the beginning
um and it and also the newer um but also
quite robust program at yale the l
prison education initiative um are both
what i would call non-reformist reforms
what do i mean by that
i think that
um part of what we should be
understanding when we're thinking about
non-reformist reforms
is ways in which
some of the
logic of the carceral logic and the
implications of carceral logic can be
undone
but the prison remains and the education
is happening in prison i'm not
advocating that the prison remains but
i'm suggesting that in the moment when
the prison exists
um the
the that it's possible to provide
educational opportunities that allow
those people who are incarcerated and
able to enroll in various classes to be
able to get their um opportunities that
they didn't have to be exposed to ideas
that they didn't actually weren't
exposed to prior
um that they're also able to develop
their own ways of thinking about
themselves in relationship to others in
relationship to the state in
relationship to our our
fragile democracy or non-existent
democracy um in relation to all sorts of
social and political structures so why
is it's a non-reformist reform because
in
we even though those of us who do this
work
um
you know have to abide by the carceral
rules
of the um departments of correction
um we can work within those systems
within the first version of carceral
logics
to undermine
the very sort of strategies of carceral
logics to undermine the very attitudes
that are part of the carceral logics
i've also included the freedom reads
project which is another i think
non-reformist reform putting freedom
libraries micro libraries of 500 books
into prisons all across the country
and i also included here on this slide
some ideas about
mutual aid that has become really
important in the context of the pandemic
where communities are working together
to help each other
outside of the various systems that are
confining and containing and have
colonized our our thinking
so
um part of the mutual aid process um has
involved redirecting local budgets to
help those who are
food insecure or
housing housing insecure or vulnerable
to substance use
developing opportunities to support
youth to create creating community-based
harm reduction programs
working on supporting victims of harm
through restorative justice practices
and holding those who caused harm
accountable in a non-carceral way
as well as other practical efforts to
build a more caring world and these
sorts of community programs i think are
extraordinarily meaningful
because they both allow for community
accountability but they also allow us to
re-imagine our social relations outside
of these carceral logics
many of you may be thinking at least i
um i would have thought this at one
point in my life that this is all
utopian this is a kind of um
utopian notion
um
and in some ways i do think that's true
i think that um it may very well be
utopian but i'm trying to reframe my
thinking about utopia i'll say a bit
about that in a sec but this is a really
i think important um insight that i
learned from a philosopher william perez
who writes that utopias have been
attempts to carve an alternative space
of life that was sufficiently
disconnected from the dominant social
order
utopia need not concern itself with
designing a perfect life
instead utopia may take up the task of
creating social spaces that allow for
deliberation
over different ideas about how we might
organize our social relations
utopia is the creation of an alternative
public sphere for testing out ideas
and disagreements
over novel forms of social life
so in this sense
i think
all social theorizing
might be thought to be utopian
confinement captivity and carceral
logics that i've been discussing are so
central to our social imagination that
it's challenging to think beyond them
and utopian thinking is what will help
unsettle our imaginations so we can
start to expand the horizons of
possibility
to move beyond cultural logics and their
punitive
manifestations in practice we need what
abolitionist erica minor calls for
quote a jailbreak of the imagination
in order to make the impossible possible
utopian thinking can free the
imagination from the constraints of the
violent oppressive and limiting social
conditions that currently exist in the
us but such thinking is not only aimed
at some hope for a peaceful future
by imagining otherwise
we are being asked to think in
fundamentally different new ways and one
of the new ways i'd like to talk about
as i wind down my discussion tonight is
what i'm calling
an abolitionist ethic of care
an abolitionist ethic of care would
focus on the particularities of caring
relationships informed by differences in
context
as well as the racial economic ethnic
cultural and differently gendered
experiences of individuals and those
they care for in community
an ethics of care i think is well suited
to be the basis of an abolitionist
practice
care ethics
in more general terms allows us to
formulate better understandings of
ethical problems
we turn to ethical theories in
conditions of conflict generally all
ethical theories to gain insights into
how we might find solutions to hard to
solve social and political issues
an ethic of care addresses situations of
conflict of course but also is concerned
with how people come to see a moral
problem as a problem in the first place
and works to develop moral imagination
not only as a way of reframing problems
but also as a way to move towards more
just and sustainable solutions to those
kinds of problems
in the exercise of moral imagination
care ethics is attentive to differences
in power
as well as the cultural underpinnings of
systems of exploitation commodification
and cruelty
by analyzing the specific context in
which systems of power operate
care ethics is concerned about the
larger structures that allow and
contribute to various forms of injustice
and inequality
care ethics also directs our attention
to the specific particular people that
are involved in the conflicts and in so
doing helps us to reframe our concerns
it encourages the development of empathy
and compassion
but care is also a capacity that has to
be nurtured
or cared for
care needs to be nurtured and cared for
itself
and carceral logics another feature of
carceral logic is they detach us from
care
and they promote that sort of detachment
an abolitionist ethic would involve
reimagining our caring relations and
encourage
and deepen them
it also requires an analysis
of the impacts of failures of care
both before carceral solutions are
sought when harms are committed
and in critiquing the dehumanizing
conditions that exist in carceral spaces
an abolitionist ethic of care can help
both victims
and those who caused harm reframe their
experiences
part of the solution to seemingly
intractable conflicts is to care for
oneself
in relations of respect
and also self-respect
as feminist thinker sarah ahmed notes
and here she's drawing on another
feminist thinker
audre lorde work this is a quote
the work of self-care is about the
creation of community fragile
communities assembled out of the
experiences of being shattered
we reassemble ourselves through the
ordinary everyday and often painstaking
work of looking after ourselves and
looking after each other
end quote an ethics of care is not meant
to be a sort of condescending
intervention where care covers over pity
or some equally contemptuous attitude
but rather it's an ethic that works to
create the conditions in which caring
for oneself and for others are developed
practiced and valued it's restorative
and transformative work
carceral logics lead us to misguided
attempts to try to bring about some sort
of justice
as i've tried to suggest tonight there
are alternatives to this way of thinking
and feeling that inflicts more harm and
does very little to fundamentally change
people's attitude towards the harm
caused by these logics
abolitionists have been working to
develop ways of reimagining our
relationships and our responses to harm
that don't involve punitive carceral
actions
an abolitionist ethic of care is a
promising area for revaluing those who
are harmed those who car cause harm and
the broader community who are impacted
not just by the pain of harms that have
been committed but by the harms that are
inflicted by the state in their name
caring empathetic
reimagining
is what we need to escape carceral
logics
and it's crucial
to promoting and achieving freedom
thanks
i look forward to this discussion
thank you professor groon uh that was
that was great um
now i'm uh
uh so if uh please place your questions
in the q a
and i will moderate i'll go through them
and moderate
uh moderate debate
so
so let's begin i guess um
so so let's begin first with uh
with uh one one question
which is about
um
which is about uh
can you connect this to your work so so
you're you're a theorist of the ethics
of captivity uh one of the one of the
questions
saw i think very clearly
the link between
your arguments and your position on
animal ethics uh do you want to talk
about that link and expand on it yeah
thanks for asking about that um so
um
there's
work that i you you heard me say a
little bit throughout uh the discussion
that they're um that i'm interested in
thinking about this in terms of animals
as well and the ways in which species
itself might be a type of carceral logic
um and so
um importantly the work that i was
thinking about um
it i i started to realize and this is
very dangerous and i'm well aware of the
dangers and so i want to just highlight
caveat
these are not comparisons between
animals in captive environments say zoos
and humans in prisons or gulags or other
kinds of cultural enclosure but i so i'm
not i'm not making a sort of simplistic
comparison here but i do think that the
underlying the background ideas the
logic that allows for
the kinds of things i talked about
disposability incapacity
um disrespect
lack of value
permanent injury those are the kinds of
things that i think are part of the
conceptualization that's a feature of
the carceral logic that allows for and
is
um sort of before prior to the existence
of these cultural spaces and so i think
there's a very tight link between the
ways in which
um we imagine our humans imagine some
humans imagine themselves um as being in
a position of just clear domination in
some scalanatra about we're just higher
up than these other animals um and
similarly and importantly you know the
sort of racist attitudes are very
similar that they're somehow higher you
know the the aryan is higher up
um so i think these are part um part and
parcel of the same kind of project
um and i do have a project
um a book coming out with a law
professor
um at the university of denver denver
justin marceau in which we talk about
these parallels um it's called
carcerologics human captivity and animal
confinement it'll be out in may
uh and i and uh and professor groon is
you know i uh that question really
revealed
brought out the way
uh that
that uh
that uh that um
your talk clearly generalized to that in
the way that your philosophical position
does as well
um so uh so let's go to an edgy question
um
yale perpetuates carceral logics
how can we use methods of non-reformist
reform to challenge these farmers
well i think i need a little bit more
context for the um ways the specific
ways in which yale does this i think
it's not uh it's not actually just yale
i mean i do think our institution
institutions like
the logic
shoots through the institutions in which
we do non-reform in which we discuss
these matters that's right that's right
and so how does one deal with that kind
of performative contradiction the aren't
you a hypocrite dot dot right yeah no
and i think that's a the performative
contradiction point is a really
important one and i think that you know
if you go back to the origins of the
notion of um
of
non-reformist reforms it's in the
context of thinking about what to do can
we make any small changes or do we have
to wait for the socialist revolution um
i think that um
the idea of of
non-reformist reforms is that
um and i re the reason i like using
mutual aid as a really important um
example of that is that you don't go
to the system to ask the system to help
with the problem because the system is
designed to make it so you need help
with the problem right so the and this
is part of the the idea is that you know
people say the prison system is broken
no the prison system is working exactly
the way it was designed to work so
making modest reforms in that system is
not going to do anything to undo this
system and i think with every
institution obviously i mean we're this
is part of what i was saying at the
beginning we're in a position where
it's really hard to imagine outside of
these structures i'm not pretending that
somehow philosophically i can just sort
of will this imagination into existence
that's not at all what i'm suggesting um
it's it's a very very very hard project
but i do think there are various ways um
that we can develop
uh different social relations and um you
know and we can think about it in terms
of you know there's there's movement
afoot around getting rid of grades for
example that would be something that
would be of non-reformist reform you
could still go to school but you argue
that we don't want grades um that that
those are the kinds of things that i
think people can do ultimately these
these aren't going to be top down sort
of changes either what you want to have
is
in a community in a group
hopefully an inclusive group with
multiple
um i
people who are in multiple social and
political locations working together and
i know that there are sort of all sorts
of activities at yale that that are
that are like that there are lots and
lots of folks um who are doing really
important uh non-reformist reform work
there
right
what sorry just the codisalts of the to
the points you made like rod ferguson
points out that the purpose of uh like
the university ombudsman
is to get people to complain
not
is to undercut any student movement that
might occur to get people to complain to
the institution itself to fix the
problem so then they can make minor
reforms without challenging the
institution itself to make the
institution itself the place where you
complain to make sure that the
institution is always the logic
governing everything that's a good cut
of style another way of thinking about
that and more pertinent in my my world
lately is that
um
you know the faculty might organize for
better benefits or better pay
um and the university in sort of enlist
certain members of the faculty and says
okay let's give you better benefits and
you better pay
or let's give everybody a little bit of
a benefit but not the full benefit it's
sort of a sort of co-opting the problem
and that was that was this exact um set
of debates that went on between
revolution and reform in the early
moment when people were arguing in favor
of of non-reformist reforms a really
important question
right so right so there's a structure to
to institutional
uh
abolition
and we can think of institutional
abolition say uh uh you know
dramatic uh
generally and then there's a structure
to counter abolition which is to allow
incremental reforms
yeah that's right
so
uh jennifer klein
uh asks
uh
so for our my distinguished uh
uh labor historian here at yale
to use ethics of care as a foundation
for abolitions
uh abolition do we do we need to also
question the premise of liberal
citizenship that fetishizes independence
care is about relations of
interdependence yet our political
culture disdains and stigmatizes
anything that can be cast as dependence
so how do we reconcile dominant
citizenship ideas of the model you
present
or change them also kathy week discusses
utopian thinking not as having to be
fully formed rather as bridge to the
alternative structure we want yes yes
great questions super questions
i highly recommend the care manifesto
that came out last year um by the care
collective and i think it does really
think we need to if you're really going
to think about abolition in a full-blown
way which i did not do in this talk at
all uh but if we're going to think about
it in a full-blown way we are absolutely
going to have to reconsider um the kind
of
um liberal citizen formation um that
exists and i think that there are
different forms of care ethics um
my my idea of care ethics is not one um
in which you can internalize or the
system can co-op care
um so sort of basically pay for care or
even you know make it so that it's part
of the system that's absolutely
something that we see happening all
around um particularly vivid in the
pandemic times
um so i think that it's important to
think about an ethics of care as a much
more fundamentally
relational
idea it isn't going to be an idea that's
based on
independence or individualism
or any of those kinds of distinguishing
detaching notions um it's a fundamental
um it's a fundamentally and i think the
quote from
uh sarah ahmad is making a point of this
that that the self is in
inextricable relation with others that
this isn't and what i call entangled
relation with others and these are
um
these aren't things to try to
disentangle but to try to navigate to
negotiate and to build better relations
and so
um i think absolutely in the political
realm there will need to be
um a very important discussion and there
have you know there have been people
doing this work joan toronto's another
who's done really important work in
rethinking how care can fit into
a rearrangement of political relations
i'm still mute um let me turn now to a
student in the class
uh who has two questions let's i'll
start with the first and then go to
another question um so the first is
about uh cancel the uh the reproduction
of carceral logics uh in in cancel
culture um this this i'm gonna add to
this as as uh so the uh so um
so the argument for this statement
follows as cancel culture does not focus
on teaching people the error of their
ways just places them outside the circle
of public view in a similar way to how
prisons label people as problems and
sequester them from society i'd love to
hear your thoughts about this
i think that's an excellent question and
i think that's exactly right i think
that there is a cultural uh logic that's
operating in cancer culture um i think
two though importantly and this is what
i was trying to get at when i didn't
again not didn't have time to fully
develop the idea but there is a kind of
effective um
longing as it were for something to go
right and i think that
um presumably there's an important way
in which what we should be
recognizing in cancel culture
is that um
there's a already something
sort of disturbed
in our in our thinking that makes us
want to cancel someone else now that
isn't to say so i i i think i i don't
want to in any way sort of overly
psychologize that longing i think it's
um i think it's a it it's it speaks
to
the ways that our
social relations
are
shallow or
not robust or there's something missing
in our social relations um and it's in
virtue of that that we develop these
kinds of us damn good like you you guys
are the good guys and we're the bad guys
um and i think that i think you know you
talk about this too in in in your
fascism book but there's this us them
thing is is um
has a certain kind of
uh
hold on us when we live in a broken
state i guess that's what i say when i
say a broken society when what when um
our fundamental humanity and our
fundamental animality isn't being
addressed or isn't being attended to and
that develop so then we
one way to respond to that sort of
social
um hollowness if you will um is to sort
of develop this okay i'm going to cancel
you or you're you have to be set aside
now i do want to say this makes this
brings to mind a really important point
that i want to make
um about abolition more generally
um
there i i think it's also really
important to keep in mind and cancel
culture is somewhat connected to this
that there are actually people who we
don't want to
interact with we don't want in our
communities we don't want
and i'm not pretending that everybody is
somebody that we could
sort of that we should embrace so i want
to i want to also acknowledge this isn't
pollyanna it might be utopian but it's a
different kind of utopia and it's not
pollyannish it's not like oh let's all
get along no it's nothing like that
um so uh the next question from joe
fishel is uh is um
is about the relationship between
carceral logics and uh
and punitive logic
um
and uh
so so
uh
so so there's how uh
what do we do
and then it shifts so the first question
is about
analytically separating carceral logic
from from
punitive logics or punitive imaginaries
and then and then professor official
wonders
what do we do with sort of the desire
for libidinized retribution
so
right um i'm not separating carceral
logics from punitive logics there's a
part of that punitive logic that is
is part of the carceral it's sort of
subsumed carcero logic subsumes um that
uh retributives retributive
sort of instinct or impulse and um
and so then there so then the question
becomes okay so so there's a distinction
to be made there i'm not sure it matters
um i i like to think i mean i like to
talk about it in terms of carceral
logics precisely because of the point
that uh professor stanley made that i'm
interested in captivity in a general way
um punishment itself um
is
a is an interesting separate question
but my interests are
um in the captive in the carceral and
punishment is a feature of that whole
system um
but i think the idea of retributivism um
is uh and the impulse towards it that
feeling that i was evoking at the
beginning of my talk where i encouraged
us to be thinking about why it is that
we want these
is particularly people in power who
abuse their power to be punished
um i think again i would just go back to
to what i was saying that desire and i'm
not denying that it's there because it
is there and i have it too um
but that desire is a feature of a
distorted system right and you know i
can't help but think of catherine
mckinnon whenever i talk about this
which is you know essentially that we
can't really out-think
um we can't think about what it might be
like catherine mckinnon uses the sort of
idea about sexual desire but the the
notion is like
we don't really know what it would be
like um to have genuine desire
outside of patriarchy because we live in
patriarchy and i think the same thing is
something that i would want to say i
don't i think the desires that we have
for punishment and retribution
are a feature of the cultural system
that we
live in and the cultural logic that's
colonized our thinking and that if we're
able to get beyond that carceral logic
and i hope we could do that through
thinking
really thinking and imagining otherwise
um
through a kind of abolitionist ethic of
care that we might actually be able to
figure out that we're not committed to
retributivism and in philosophy in the
philosophy of law and philosophy of
punishment there's been a lot of debates
about sort of what what what's the what
is the underlying moral um ethical
political uh
values that are
achieved through punishment and
i think already this is a good example
of something that you're buying into the
carceral system so we're gonna debate at
the edges should it be retributive or
should it be you know like we're trying
to um deter people or is this just
really a utilitarian way of dealing with
but that already is within the system
and my view is that we really need to
challenge the system of thinking about
um
why we wh why that's the way we want to
organize our lives so for example what
would we do with somebody who was really
egregious nobody could handle
um
i don't know put them
just you know turn your back on them or
don't let them into your home or don't
let them into your community or don't
let them into your space um
so so the way i understand it
your response is um an idea don't think
of carceral logic as like a set of
principles think of it as an ideology
where an ideology is principles
practices and attitudes and emotions to
things
and you've got to eliminate the entire
ideology the desire for retribution is
part of an ideology an ideology is not
just a logic
and hopefully if we get rid of the
structure
you know the hypothesis is we'll get rid
of those feelings of retribution
though it does seem to me that the
feelings of retribution
um
last through
a number of different forms of
punishment
even before
the the
the prison say
um the carceral logic you're trying to
get rid of is much deeper than just the
prison yeah yeah that's right
wow
shelly asks about how we broaden this so
professor is a very distinguished uh
philosopher of disability uh
uh
asks how we how we include
uh carceral logics and abolition how we
broaden that to include institutions and
social phenomena such as nursing homes
psych wards group homes for disabled
people etc
well um that's i mean i have i i put
them in that list um earlier shelly uh
professor partly because you've done
such important and interesting work and
continue to do work particularly through
the pandemic on these on these
institutions um but that's partly why
it's really important to think about
this as just as professor stanley was
just saying as an ideology or as i'm
thinking of it an overarching logic that
applies beyond the prison situation
every and beyond the zoo i think i mean
we really need to think um about those
as canonical cases um
but there are
there are many many places in which
um
the the structure is designed precisely
um to
um hold on to
those that are within it um in a
diminished way and it's it's re the
institutions require that um there's
also um
some really important work on
de-institutionalization um that's um
been done
that is particularly in the in the area
of psychiatric institutions um that also
takes abolition in a very special and
important direction um so obviously i
couldn't speak to all of these issues
including the animal issue that is so
sort of close to my heart um tonight but
thank you for raising that shelley
i i'm going to put myself in the queue
even though that's a slight violation of
decorum uh so i wanted to go back to
professor klein's question about liberal
citizenship and ask about you know ask a
sort of maybe devil's advocacy kind of
question about the ethics of care
background to your work which uh so
there's a way of attacking there's a way
of of of going at this
which which leans on liberal citizenship
which says that that what's happening in
prisons is a violation of equality of
citizenship uh and when you're asking
people to be responsible for their
actions your treat you're considering
them as equal citizens uh this is the
kind of thing that that uh that douglas
says and what to the slave is the fourth
of july it's like you're not
dehumanizing us you know because you're
treating us as responsible for our
actions but then this method of treating
us is sort of
uh it undercuts the equality of
citizenship that that taking us as
responsible for our actions uh seems to
presuppose
um
but all of that is within the framework
of liberal citizenship um there's a kind
of you know the the kind of the kind so
um
you know the way i think of it i mean i
i one kind of reason i'm attracted to is
well this is just this kind of treatment
of fellow citizens is incompatible with
treating them as responsible for their
actions treating them as equal citizens
in this more full blood-blooded liberal
sense what survives from that
um
that's a very different basis one that
doesn't generalize
uh as much as an ethics of care
view does to say captivity of animals
well okay so there's a lot in that and
if i'm understanding
i mean i think that
the problem with um the liberal
citizenship model
is it um i mean it buys into or it's
presupposes a very specific form of
um
agency a very specific form of
responsibility a very specific form of
identity that is
part of upholding the liberal framework
so it
it has this um it has this way in which
um
we uh
we have
a framework that imagines us as sort of
um individuals outside of social
political familial
intimate
relations
and then it creates the conditions for
making it so that if we
don't do something it looks like our
freedom or our agency is being violated
i'm not making the
what i'm trying to suggest is that
sort of there's a self-fulfilling um and
a self-sustaining part of liberal
citizenship that makes it seem and it
you know it does it's not just liberal
citizenship it's kant i mean it's
actually it goes it goes farther back um
in a sense so that there's this idea
that what it means to be responsible
what it means to be an agent
what it means to be
a
a member of a functioning ethical world
is that i have value
my value
is tied to myself as recognizing that
value as as professor chris coursgard
would say it's tethered to me
um and i want to go back farther than
that and say no that that presupposition
that we somehow sort of appear
as individuals fully formed
um is just a fiction and that that
fiction
i get that's what you want to do but it
doesn't seem
i mean i think in other words you can
have a kantian abolitionist program uh
though i mean you haven't argued that
you can't uh right right right yeah you
have an argue that you can right but
you've presented but abolition in the
ethics of caring framework is a much
more philosophically radical program
than you know you can you can imagine an
abolitionist program extending from
abolition of slavery that's
ideologically consistent with it that
remains within the liberal tradition
right right right right no i think that
that i mean that's a really important
point and i think that i wasn't arguing
actually in that in that vein um i do
think that there's a sense however um
that that we can get in trouble
at some juncture if we go that route um
and the trouble is that we're
reinforcing the system that's built on i
mean incarceral logics come out of that
system and so i don't know how that
system can survive without carceral
logic but it's an important point and i
should probably think about the it's a
very important point that i should
probably think about the ways in which
i i didn't argue this but i think there
is an important sense in which
um the
the
sort of genesis as it were of the car
the relationship of the genesis of the
carceral logic and this liberal citizen
notion um is is actually um
i think worth my
sort of cashing out a little bit thank
you i mean murukawa i think tries to
argue that liberalism results in the
incarceration but i don't think it's
you know i love naomi markawa's work but
i don't think i'm not completely
convinced that right right you know that
it's not a contingent fact of history
what mikhail markawa describes and uh
okay let me go to more questions um
so uh
so let's see um
uh
oh i mean oh wow oh sorry i was on the
uh okay open
ah here we are um so uh
uh so
um
uh
so uh so once uh let me let me just look
to see um
uh
uh right
um
uh right uh
uh professor klein weighs in to to to
point out that the people who developed
the asylum and the penitentiary uh
saw them as involved in a project of
care
um right and that's definitely one thing
even solitary confinement was was
envisaged in eastern states penitentiary
yeah that way right that's right that's
right i mean and that's i mean and it
but i think that it's important um
i don't um
i mean i think that these notions of
care i i think the idea of
um care is not just i care so i'm gonna
i'm gonna say
um you know so
solitary con early early forms of
solitary confinement as lisa gunther so
um brilliantly points out um were
designed precisely to care for the
person who's gone astray and allow them
time to reflect on themselves and to
develop sort of a quiet mind you know
this so that they can move um in a very
uh
work
more productive direction um and i think
that that's partly i i hinted at this
care as i'm understanding it is not that
sort of condescending paternalistic
pitying sort of notion and there is i
think important debate um amongst care
theorists about
what sorts of care we're talking about
and there is just to go back to your
earlier point um there's a very rich
tradition of liberal care theorists that
are developing views about when can care
be
monetized when can it be sort of
incorporated into a sort of financial
exchange when is in those sorts of
questions that isn't the care i'm
thinking about but of course it exists
yes
professor klein notes an
anti-hierarchical form of collected care
care collective care is what we need um
so um
so uh
uh zoar uh again uh another question
from a student um who wants to hear
about your thoughts on endowment justice
activism and in particular how it
measures up as a kind of non-reformist
reform
um so if uh so i think this is a really
exciting and interesting question and
thinking um i'm i would like to hear a
little bit
more about this kind of activism but if
if i'm thinking of what i'm what it
triggers for me it's this idea that
somehow um
this whole uh
well
maybe you can tell me
before i start launching into this well
uh so
so um this is like you know asking the
university to no longer be invested in
fossil fuels okay that's what i think
okay i just wanted to make sure that's
what i was thinking but then i thought
wait maybe there's some other thing here
right so i mean i think these kinds of
things um
aren't
they um
i don't know if they are non-reformist
um
i i think
um ultimately and this is tricky but
ultimately
sort of moving around
capital from one thing to another holds
on to the structure
um and so i my sense is that just as
divestment
in the area of fossil fuels for example
um and you know or techno solutions to
you know climate change sort of all of
those things are part of are just not
another form of um
sort of
maintaining the system
um i i i know that's a harsh thing to
say but i think if you think about
non-reformist reforms seriously um it
really doesn't mean that you can move
money from one drawer to the other
that's
too reformist it's not non-reformist
what you would need to do is take the
money from that drawer and give it to
the people who don't have any money that
would be non-reformist but that's not
what we're talking about while we're
talking about divesting so
um i don't i think that's just a reform
it's not a non-reformist reform
uh
uh
yes um
sometimes i worry that the kinds of
reforms we ourselves get involved in
we are was wishful thinking that they're
non-reformist reforms but that's that's
just simply how life is right and that's
the i mean i do want to just say this i
mean i i this is hard this is i mean
this is hard intellectually this is hard
emotionally this is hard
to do in the system and it's it's
and and there really is no such thing as
clean hands no such thing as being pure
no such thing as being righteous um you
do what you can do
yeah uh and look as as christy dawson
said in that conference we ran injustice
means that all the options are bad
so uh so uh anna marie
asks a really interesting question uh
about the functioning of a criminal
court system in abolishing uh carceral
logics
um
so uh and and also
relatedly is there a difference in
wanting a conviction for the purpose of
society's disapproval of certain actions
and not necessarily wanting
incarceration
yeah so i think these are really these
are two really interesting questions i
don't think that the criminal court
system that we have ever known
um is non-carceral in fact it is
carceral logics that organizes whichever
system those might be
and there was early systems for those of
you who are interested in animals there
were early systems where animals were
put on trial um
for doing various things because animals
were thought to have agency and
responsibility um
but criminal court systems are designed
um are sort of a feature of the car
incarceral logics organizes all criminal
court systems so it's not clear to me
that you could have a non-carceral um
criminal court system
the question the second question though
is a question about
um maybe wanting um
wanting some
sort of
acknowledgement or accountability is
that is am i hearing that right without
having punishment um and that is
certainly the project of many people who
are working in restorative justice work
um and transformative justice work the
idea that
what um we want it's not that everybody
can do whatever they want and there's no
consequences and nobody's going to be
upset nobody's going to be hurt um
that's absolutely
that's that's the kind of utopianism
that i
really don't like um
it's the idea instead is that when
people
do harm when people cause harm when
people bring about harm
the way to address that is not through a
system of
a punitive system a prison system a
legal system
it's through a system of community
accountability
um and even there that's what i was
saying earlier and even through that
system of community accountability there
may be some people that just don't make
sense to have around
us in our community whatever our
community is and then we have to figure
out what to do in that kind of situation
and i could imagine that if a community
decides to say exile somebody
um that this
would to that person exiled look very
much like carceral a carceral exclusion
um
and i would hope a process would be in
pla again i'm this is all philosophical
imagination this isn't
any specific case i'm thinking about um
but i would admit i would hope that the
process would already say that if you
aren't going to be willing to work with
us in community
about accountability then this will
potentially be an outcome so it's not um
it's not something that is sprung upon
somebody who who isn't aware of it
i'm right to think right following from
your talk that
that
rethinking
uh rethinking the ideology
that is carceral logic carceral ideology
will require rethinking every
institution it can't be in or many
institutions it can't be done because
the you can't disaggregate
the prison
from the rest
from the rest of society's institutions
which replicate it uh it's uh i'm
incorporating one of the questions which
is about yale's relation
to
its community
and i'm thinking
uh which which does involve i think
elements of carceral logics
elements of uh but so i'm i'm wondering
i'm wondering so policing would be an
obvious one
but i'm wondering uh you know uh
the utopian imagination that you
describe when you talk about william
paris uh how much revision
this is a society-wide
revision right yes i mean i think it it
has to be um
and i think it has to be in multiple
dimensions obviously this is this is a
sort of
a project that like what you just
mentioned in my thinking about what this
project could look like just makes me
sort of tremble in terror of the
hugeness or the enormity of it so i'm
not going to feel comfortable at all
answering it in a way that it's like yes
oh this is what we need but i do think
it has ramifications it has
ramifications to how we treat animals if
you think about that just think about
that just think about that for a second
what would it take
to fundamentally re-think
our relationships with it i mean it
really requires starting over going
somewhere else it's it's in every part
of our system so
um i think that's part of the issue and
i think that
um carceral logics are
um so much a part of everything and we
can't part of the utopianism for me is
not just
um
can i intervene there just to yeah just
to expand on that so here we have a
difference between a liberal
abolitionist program and the kind of
ethics of care abolitionist program you
envision the liberal program would say
prisons are inconsistent with
uh with
equal liberal citizenship and so this is
not really a radical revision we're just
knocking prisons out
and uh and that will
you know if angela davis is right bring
back the prison uh if you're just if
you're just you're leaving a
prison-shaped footprint
what you're do you're saying if it's
really if the prison if you really want
to eliminate the prison you have to
reimagine have a much more fundamental
reimagine and here is a more
more fundamental reimagining i can offer
it's not just that the prison involves
treating some of citizens not as liberal
equal co-citizens
it's that the whole system needs to be
thought and then we're not going to do
this again
right that's right it will and it will
lead to it won't revert back to the
problem that we currently have and it
won't lead to
a shinier fancier
um you know sweden like car prison
system either um and and uh yeah
um okay
uh i think let's see if there are um
there are uh
oh so there's
there's one more question uh
about how an ethics of care can be
applied to quarantining and lockdown
related to covet 19 such as australia's
howard springs or whether you believe
that's relevant at all
um i'm not sure i understand fully um
the question i think that ethics of care
um
yeah i mean i i think that's not a
carceral situation
yes exactly right
okay so uh so
uh thanks everyone for attending and
thank you professor groon uh for
bringing ours for for provi bringing our
semester to an end with that
uh incredible lecture that enables us to
think through
uh this this long uh path we've we've
taken this semester so thank you for
your work and your activism um over the
years thank you for having me was a
delight and thank you for your great
questions everyone
all right
bye
bye everyone